des whatever of the journey of getting
kavik back up and running
chugga-chugga-chugga knocking stuff off
my list I have a little bit near I still
need to clean I don't have food to cook
for people but even if I wanted to make
hot cereal I can't do it right now gotta
get the kitchen done upward and onward
and on the texture I need to get the
toilets read I don't have guests coming
in I have guests here I'm out of time
the clock of Sue just ran out you know
they need to go to the restroom they
don't need to hear that Bush looks nice
this is the outhouse it is full of water
and yuck
from the melting snow and whatnot this
is human waste from obviously somebody
that came in during the winter unique
little slurry
this way kick it over point it downhill
let mother nature take care of that for
a while I've got on the ones cut and
waiting get our dry get it in you can
out out here dig a hole into the ground
and have it disappear and just cover it
up because it's a protected ecosystem
human waste
we take medicine we take pills
potentially hazard this is just another
chart on off the list I've got nine ten
people showing up tomorrow